Okay.
We are about to see true what I call Seaspan
porn.
Tomorrow.
Cspan isn't normally the place for high ratings
and exciting television, but it's usually
instead of place for endless government testimony
of all kinds.
But tomorrow we might actually have arguably
the most anticipated cspan type testimony
before elected officials, certainly in a very
long time.
And by far within the Trump presidency, I
think a close second will be Michael Cohen's
testimony.
Some months ago.
I expect former special prosecutor Robert
Mueller's testimony tomorrow to be extremely,
extremely noteworthy and newsworthy.
Um, you will recall that Robert Mueller filed
a report summarizing his investigation into
Donald Trump and in that report, not only
did he say he couldn't exonerate Trump of
obstruction, actually clarifying if we could
have exonerated him, we would have said so.
He actually indicated that on 14 possible
counts of obstructive acts by the president.
All three legal requirements to be criminal
obstruction were met on eight of those 14
possible obstructive acts and he is going
to be testifying tomorrow and Donald Trump
is truly panicking.
We don't know what Mueller is going to say,
but even if he merely states in clear terms
what's in the report, it is going to be devastating
to Donald Trump in so far as millions of Americans
have no idea what's in the report.
I've talked about this before.
William Barr in advance of the release of
the Mueller report, put out this propaganda
letter, a very calculated political document,
which was then used by Trump and the people
around him to go on a national exoneration
tour claiming no collusion, no obstruction.
And of course then the actual report came
out, doesn't match in almost any way.
It when you look at the bar letter you, if
you really read the Mueller report, you would
say the bar letter can't possibly be a about
the Mueller report, can it?
Because it bears no resemblance to the content
of the Mueller report.
And that is why millions of Americans who
are just busy living their lives, working
their jobs, earning their widely stagnant
wages, and bringing their kids to school,
uh, haven't read the Mueller report.
And so if Mueller shows up tomorrow and is
just asked about the contents of the report
and explains what's in there, that alone will
be devastating to Donald Trump.
And nevermind the fact that we might learn
about so many other things that didn't make
it into the report.
So Trump clearly panicking starts tweeting
yesterday that Robert Mueller simply shouldn't
be allowed to testify at all.
Saying, quote, highly conflicted.
Robert Mueller should not be given another
bite at the apple.
In the end, it will be bad for him and the
Phony Democrats in Congress who have done
nothing but waste time on this ridiculous
witch hunt result of the Mueller report.
No collusion, no obstruction.
So there are five lies, at least that I count
in this short tweet by Donald Trump, which
is sort of amazing, right?
The economy of words with which the president
can tell so many lies.
He says, highly conflicted.
Robert Mueller Mueller's a Republican, and
there was no evidence of any conflict.
Number two, that molar shouldn't be given
another bite at the apple, implying that the
testimony is a way for molar to get Trump
indicted.
That's not what the testimony is.
Lie Number three, it will be bad for Mueller
Mueller's in his seventies and retired.
I don't think it's gonna do much for Muller
either way.
Line number four, calling this a ridiculous
witch hunt.
There've been more than a dozen indictments,
including top Trump staffers going to prison
plus evidence in Mueller's.
Report of obstruction by the president of
the United States on eight counts.
Doesn't sound like a witch hunt and lie number
five, Mueller said, no collusion, no obstruction.
Of course, untrue.
Moeller said he could not clear Trump of obstruction
and found evidence of obstructive acts on
eight of the 14 possible counts.
Five lies in such a short tweet, but the most
disturbing thing about this is not actually
the lies.
In a sense, we've kind of become numb to the
lies.
The most disturbing thing here is Trump suggesting
that Mueller shouldn't be allowed to testify.
There's no legal justification for not allowing
Robert Muller to testify.
I don't believe Trump understands how guilty
and insecure he looks when he does this, even
though to his followers, it doesn't really
matter.
They fall for the fake news, which hunt talking
points no matter what, but this is why it's
imperative that Robert Mueller testify.
This is why it's so important that the content
of the molar report is published.
So that clear thinking, people who, again,
they're not avoiding the Mueller report per
se, they heard about the bar letter.
They're busy working, they're busy raising
kids, they're living their lives.
They simply haven't read the Mueller report
and don't know what's in it.
He must testify so that more Americans, hopefully
millions or tens of millions of Americans
are exposed to the factual, empirical content
of the report.
Trump's only objection to Mueller's testimony
in reality is molar testifying has the potential
to be really, really bad for me, me being
Trump that cannot be allowed to silence.
People will be watching tomorrow for sure.
I hope that there's no funny business in the
very end in the runup to this testimony because
it's extraordinarily important and I look
forward to seeing it and we'll be covering
it on the show.